The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So Professor Gossard
gave the lecture last week.
I'm going to pick up
where he left off.
But let's talk about the concept
questions from the homework
you've been working on.
So the first one is our cart.
You'd expect to be able
eliminate the terms involving
gravity in the
equations of motion
by choosing coordinates
with respect
to the static
equilibrium position.
So we've talked about that.
And with this one does
the restoring force
on the pendulum, what
makes it come back
to zero after it's a damped
out and hanging straight down.
AUDIENCE: Gravity.
PROFESSOR: What?
Gravity does.
And that gravity term
varies with the torque
that the gravity puts around the
pivot is MgL over 2 sine theta.
So the gravity term is involved
with the motion variable theta.
So in this case,
gravity is going
to be involved in
the natural frequency
and in the equations of
motion, no matter what,
So you will not be able to
eliminate the gravity terms.
Next, this one, this is a
vibration isolation question.
Will the addition of
damping increase or reduce
the vibration of the
table in response
to the floor motion at 30 Hertz?
I guess this depends on what the
natural frequency of the system
is.
But we're trying to do
vibration isolation.
And presuming, if
you read the problem,
you're supposed to
find a a stiffness such
that you can reduce the
response of the table by 12 dB,
I think it said, from
the motion of the floor.
So that's something
substantially less than 1.
And you will be-- this one
takes a, best described
with a picture.
The transfer function
for response of the table
over the motion of the
floor, the magnitude
of that transfer
function, that's
just the ratio of x to y.
That looks like this,
if the damping is zero.
And as you add damping, all
points cross right here.
Some damping does that.
More damping because of this.
And in order to accomplish
what's been described--
this is 1.0 here.
If you're trying to make
this table respond less
than the floor, you must
be somewhere out here
where you're below 1.
So this is omega over omega n.
And right here at
resonance, you're at 1.0.
So this is, you know, two or
three or four for this value
out here.
Let's say here's where
you find the answer to B.
And without damping,
you're there.
And that's 12 dB down.
If you add damping, it
pushes you up these curves.
Does make the response larger,
the undesirable response,
the motion of the
table larger or smaller
as you add damping at
that operating point?
It increases it, right?
OK, so in this case, will
the addition of damping
increase or reduce
the vibration?
It'll increase it.
But damping's a necessary evil.
You need some damping
in the system.
So if you bump it, it doesn't
sit there and oscillate all day
long.
Next.
OK, this is a platform.
Do you think I could
actually do it?
Did you read this?
So this is a Coast Guard
light station off of Cuttyhunk
down off of Woods
Hole-- basically,
I was doing this-- in time with
the motion of the platform.
Resonance is a wonderful thing.
If you can make
the force be right
at the natural frequency
of the structure,
it actually doesn't
take a lot of force
to drive the amplitude to
pretty large amplitudes,
if the damping is small.
So I think the damping in
this cases is about 1%.
And that means
the amplification,
the dynamic amplification
1 over 2 zeta is about 50.
So I actually could do this.
This is a true story.
OK, next.
For small motions
about the horizontal,
you expect the natural frequency
to be a function of gravity.
So this is, oh, some of
you, about equal, yes no.
But it's just horizontal, the
torque that gravity provides
is some Mg pulling down
on the center of mass
somewhere in that body.
Not at the pivot, but let's
say some distance A away.
So the torque, the gravity,
the restoring torque
is some Mg cross r cross Mg,
Mgr if r is the distance.
And that's the torque.
And that length of that
moment arm might vary.
It's going to vary
like cosine theta.
Around horizontal line, if theta
is what's, for small angles,
what's cosine?
It goes to 1.
So you find out that
this just looks like Mgr.
It's for small
angle of vibration.
And you can in fact
get it out of-- it
doesn't enter into the equation
for the natural frequency.
So the natural
frequency of a thing
won't be a function of gravity
because of this small angle
vibration around a
horizontal point.
OK.
One, when the
acceleration of the system
is one half that required to
make the mass slide, what's
the magnitude of
the friction force?
So friction is one of
those things that is only
as big as you need it to be.
So even the largest friction
that this thing can sustain
is in fact mu mg--
answer A. But f equals ma
if the acceleration
is half of what
is required to have
that thing be just slip.
It will just slip when you
are at a force which is mu mg.
And so that force is equal
to mass times acceleration.
The acceleration then
you can figure out
what that will be
just when it slips.
But now if you reduce
acceleration to half that,
the friction force required to
keep it in place is only half
as big.
And it will be
that friction force
and it will be half of mu mg.
So it's actually B.
And next-- is that it?
No.
OK.
This is a simple but
actually sometimes
hard to see through question.
What initial conditions
will be required?
This problem can be solved
by initial conditions.
This mortar launches its shell.
And the trick to this question,
the key to this question
is for your mathematical
model of the system--
your equation in motion-- is
write the equation of motion
without the shell.
Because once it shoots this
thing, the shell's gone.
And it's vibrating.
It's now a system without
that 25 kilogram mortar
shell part of the system.
It's gone.
Now it's just the
mass of the system
without the mortar shell.
And there are two
initial conditions
that then you can say when you
shot the mortar shell, that was
a certain amount of momentum.
And from conservation of
momentum you can figure out
what the momentum of the
main mass has to be-- equal
and opposite to
the shell you shot.
So that gives you
an initial velocity.
But there's also an initial
displacement in this problem.
So that's the key to
figuring this out.
So what initial conditions
would be required?
And it's C-- both
an initial velocity
and an initial displacement.
But the key is to make
your mathematical model
about the system
without the shell.
OK?
Good.
Is that it?
All right.
So today we're going
to pick up where
Professor Gossard left off.
But I'm also going to
do a bit of a summary
right now about
vibration and modeling
the different kinds of systems
that we talk about when
we talk about vibration.
They vary from simple, single
degree of freedom oscillators,
like a simple
pendulum-- one degree
of freedom-- to continuous
systems-- beams and vibrate.
So I'm going to try
to give you just
sort of an overview
of vibration just
to sort of give you a
little map of information.
Kind of to let you know what the
body of vibration analysis is
and what part of it we're
covering in this course.
So I think I will use
a little more board.
So we classify
dynamics problems into,
for convenience, rigid
bodies-- rigid body dynamics
and flexible bodies.
One way to think of it.
And this course is basically
about rigid body dynamics.
And under this we then
have two categories
that are convenient-- single
degree of freedom systems
and multiple degree
of freedom systems.
For the purposes of vendors--
talking about vibration.
Single degree of freedom systems
have one equation of motion.
And if they vibrate, they have--
and if I'll put over here--
if vibration occurs then you
have one natural frequency.
And it's sort of silly
to talk about a mode
shape for a single
degree of freedom system,
because it's only
relative to itself.
So one natural frequency and one
sort of degenerate mode shape.
Multiple degree
of freedom systems
have n equations of motion
for the number of degrees
of freedom.
And if they vibrate they
have n omega i's, or m values
of omega i for i equals 1 to n.
You get n natural
frequencies of the system.
And you will get with
it n mode shapes.
So a n degree of
freedom, this is
equal to the number
of degrees of freedom.
An n degree of
freedom system will
have n natural
frequencies and n mode
shapes that go along with it.
Now, what about what
about flexible bodies?
So a taut string
like a guitar string.
And actually I should say
over here these rigid body
things-- we have found what
kind of equations of motion?
These are ordinary
differential equations.
And there's a finite number
of them and so forth.
The flexible bodies
like taut strings
are described by partial
differential equations.
The number of
degrees of freedom n
here is the number
of degrees of freedom
actually goes to infinity.
And you get an infinite
number of omega i's,
the natural frequencies,
and an infinite number
of corresponding mode shapes.
So just about everything in the
world can be made to vibrate.
So how do you tell if a--
you've got a mechanical system,
rigid bodies, you've got
three degrees of freedom.
How do you know whether or
not it's going to vibrate?
It will exhibit vibration?
Well, one thing you
could do is figure out
all the equations of
motion and solve them
and see if cosine
omega t is a solution.
Right?
That's the hard way.
The other way is to go up
to it and give it a smack
and see if it vibrates.
That's the simple way.
If you have the mechanical
system just give it a whack.
And if it oscillates around some
stable equilibrium position,
it exhibits vibration.
So this is a flexible system.
You can actually probably
see this from there.
Just by giving this frame a
smack, it will sit and vibrate.
And it does it at some
natural frequency.
But that's a continuous system.
This continuously
improving little demo--
so Professor Gossard for
his lecture last weekend
had done this really
neat embellishment,
which allows you to figure
out and excite the two
different natural modes.
But this system you have
equations of motion for it.
You could write it.
And if you come up and give
it a whack, it oscillates.
And you could also find out that
sure enough cosine omega t sine
omega t are solutions to
the equations of motion.
So systems that
vibrate are systems
that oscillate about static
equilibrium positions.
And another way
you can say that is
when mechanical
vibration occurs,
there's always an
exchange of energy
between kinetic and potential,
kinetic and potential.
So our pendulum
it goes-- when it
reaches zero velocity up here,
it's all potential energy.
It reaches maximum velocity
down here, it's all kinetic.
And it goes back and forth.
As it sloshes back and
forth the energy system
from kinetic to
potential and back again.
All vibration has that property.
So that sets some basic
properties of vibration.
And now there's a whole body
of knowledge about vibration.
And we choose, or for the
purposes of this class,
we choose to break it down
into two kinds of vibration.
And one is what we
call free vibration.
And that we've learned already
is response, only a response.
It's a response to
initial conditions
and what we call
forced vibrations.
Now, forces can
come of all kinds.
And for the purposes
of this course
we look at a particular
kind of force.
So we focus on
harmonic excitation.
So excitation that is of
the form cosine omega t,
or e to the i omega t.
These are external excitations.
So we choose to break
down the analysis
of the vibration of
systems into response
to initial conditions
called free vibration,
no external forces,
and force vibration.
But we focus on a
particular kind-- harmonic.
And we go even one step
further and say we're only
going to study steady state.
And steady state means
you've waited a long time.
Turned it on, let it
shake for quite awhile.
All the initial
startup transients
have been damped out.
And you're left with a
steady state vibration.
And that leads to things
like the transfer functions
for single degree
of freedom systems
that we've talked about.
Now, there's one other
breakdown or subdivision
that we need to talk about.
And that is whether systems
are linear or non-linear.
And this is all set
up so you can see it.
This is a double pendulum.
How many degrees of freedom?
Two.
And in general, do you think
the equations of motion
of this thing are
going to be non-linear?
Right.
Just a simple pendulum
is the restoring torque
is Mgl sine theta.
So you know it's got
sine theta and that.
And this one gets quite messy.
And especially if you
give it large amplitudes.
And that really isn't vibration.
It's not.
It's looping all over itself
and then doing other things.
So cosine omega t
is not a solution.
It's not a solution to this.
It's got to be more
complicated than that.
So when this thing is
exhibiting large motions,
the equations of motion
are completely non-linear.
And you're going
to need a computer
to crank out the full
solution to integrate
these non-linear
equations of motion.
But as the amplitude settles
down to something pretty small,
now it's vibrating about
an equilibrium position.
The equilibrium position
is straight down.
And the damping of
it has made it such
that the only motion
left is what's called
its first mode of vibration.
And so if we linearize
the equations of motion,
assuming small amplitudes around
static equilibrium positions,
then we can find a
vibration solution
and work it out
by hand probably.
That's first mode
for this system.
And if I'm careful--
there's second mode.
And for small
oscillations it has
a very clear single frequency
that it vibrates at.
The amplitude decays over
time because of damping.
And for every natural
frequency there
is a particular mode
shape that goes along
with that natural frequency.
The first one for
this system-- I
have to wait for this
thing to damp out.
It's got a little
mix of the two,
but as it-- the second
natural frequency motion
dies out faster than
the first because it
has more cycles per unit time.
So it settles down.
This is now mostly
first mode vibration.
And you can see that both
move in the same direction,
the bottom one a little
more than the top.
And that's the first mode.
It has a unique
natural frequency.
And a mode shape that is
specific that goes along
with that natural frequency.
So this further break
down here, I'll call it,
is basically into
non-linear and linearized.
So in our discussions of
vibration in this course
we basically only
talk about this.
So we're only doing-- so
that's quite a breakdown.
You start at all possible
vibration systems,
rigid bodies, single
degree of freedom,
multidegree of freedom, finite
number of degrees of freedom
or continuous.
They can have linear or
non-linear equations of motion.
But if we require
them to be linear,
and that's what we're
going to look at then
you sort of narrow this down
what we're looking at to this.
So there's lots of other
things possible to look
at it, like that really
non-linear motion of that two
dimensional thing.
But our study of
vibration is here.
So this is what
we're doing in 2003.
But there's a lot of
important problems
that are covered by that.
Lots of real things
in nature that
are problematic for engineers
and problematic for design
can be analyzed with
linear equations of motion.
And even if they're not linear,
if you do the linear solution
first, it gives you
a starting point
to think about
what's the behavior
of the non-linear systems.
But this is our
study of vibration.
And we're going to do
that for-- and what we had
started doing-- in two ways.
We look at the response to
initial conditions called
free vibration.
And we look at
response, steady state
response of now these linear
systems to force vibration.
And last week you were
looking for the first time
at Professor Gossard's lecture
about the free vibration
response of basically a
two degree freedom system.
So why do two degree
of freedom systems?
Well, it's the simplest next
step up from a single degree.
And they're sort of
mathematically tractable.
You can do them on paper.
We emphasize looking at
two degree freedom systems
because we can do the
math on the board,
do the math on the paper.
But as you get to more
degrees of freedom,
you basically are going to
have to do-- it's easier
to do it using the computer.
And in order to do that you need
to know some linear algebra.
So I'm kind curious.
In terms of linear algebra,
like multiplying two matrices
together, or finding the
determinant of a matrix,
or inverting a matrix,
how many of you
actually have been taught that?
How may perhaps have it?
Do you do that in 1803 now?
Is that where you do it?
OK.
Good.
So that's helpful.
I wasn't sure whether or not.
I can assume that you
at least know what
the determinant of a matrix is.
That's great.
That's really helpful.
OK.
Let's talk.
So we want linear
equations of motion.
And I've done a little bit about
linearization but not much.
So let's talk a little bit
about that for a second.
For a pendulum we know the
equation of motion for it.
And actually we could make this
a more complicated pendulum.
It could be a stick or any rigid
body swinging about this point
A.
We know that we can write
the equation of motion Izz
with respect to A, theta
double dot, plus Mgl-- omega L.
The distance here to wherever
g is, Mgl sine theta.
And for free vibration
that's all there is to it.
And to linearize this
equation we just say,
well, we know that sine theta
is equal to theta minus theta
cubed over 3 factorial plus
theta to the fifth over 5
factorial.
And the cosine theta-- just
to have it available here--
is 1 minus theta squared over
2 factorial and so forth.
And when we say
linearize, we really
mean we want our equations to
involve the motion variables
at most to first order.
So the first order
term for sine is theta.
There's no first
order term for cosine.
Theta squared is non-linear.
So the small angle
approximation to cosine
is it's approximately 1.
And to sine is
it's approximately
theta for small motions.
Theta-- small.
So when we linearize
this equation,
we just substitute in for sine
theta its linear approximation.
And we get Mgl theta.
So we've seen that
one many times.
And that's your linearized
equation of motion.
But on this week's homework
you've got a harder problem.
And that's our cart.
And here you have a theta and
an x are your two equations.
And you've worked
this problem before.
And you know with the
previous homeworks you've
gotten the equation of motion.
I'll write one of
them down here.
So one of the
equations of motion
is-- this is m1, m1, k, b.
And this is a stick, it's
l long, g in the middle.
So the equation of motion for
this looks like m1 plus m2, x
double dot plus m2 l
over 2, theta double dot,
minus m2 l over 2 theta
dot squared theta,
and then plus bx dot,
plus kx, and equals,
and in fact, this one
has a force on it.
It's equal to F of t.
Now, is that a
non-linear equation?
So this is the
force equation mass
times acceleration or forces.
You know you've got
another equation of motion
in here, which is
the torque one.
This is just one of them.
So is it linear or non-linear?
How many think it's non-linear?
OK.
If I have number the terms
here-- one, two, three, four,
five.
And that's not a motion.
This doesn't involve motion.
So if one through five, which
ones have a non-linear term?
AUDIENCE: Three.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Three.
OK.
So how do you
linearize that thing?
AUDIENCE: You make it zero,
because it's second order.
J. KIM VANDIVER: In
fact, it's third order.
So the reason I wanted
to mention this today--
if you haven't thought
about being confronted
with linearization
problems before-- we're
trying to linearize
the system so that we
can by making it linear we can
make cosine omega t a solution.
Right?
We want cosine omega t to
be a solution to this thing.
So if you let-- so
you've got a term that
looks like ml over m2l over
2, theta dot squared theta.
Well, theta in this problem
of some function of time
we're hoping-- we want
to find a solution that
has some amplitude times,
say, a cosine omega t.
And theta dot is minus omega
theta naught sine omega t.
And so that expression
up there, the magnitude
of that expression or the
magnitude of theta dot
squared theta is proportional
to-- you get a theta
naught here and you
get omega squared
theta naught squared here.
So this term is proportional
to theta naught cubed.
And if the angle theta is
small, then a small angle cubed
is really small.
And so the way you
linearize this equation
is to throw this out.
So when you've done all
your tricks you can,
like replacing sine theta
with theta and cosine theta
with one, and you still end
up with terms have a higher
order than one in the
motion variable, theta or x,
you throw it out.
So if you throw that
term out then you
end up with a nice linear
equation in motion.
OK.
So now for the
rest of today we're
going to talk about
free vibration solution.
So we're not going to worry
for the moment about the force
vibration steady state
transfer function stuff.
We're talking just
about free vibration.
And this is of linear
equations of motion.
So vibration is a pretty
big body of knowledge.
And we're doing an introduction
to vibration in about half
a dozen lectures here.
So there's lots of
things that I'm not
going to have time to
teach you, but there
are a few things I really
want you to go away with
and understanding.
And one of these key concepts
is that the vibration
of a multiple degree
of freedom system--
say this is a two degree
of freedom system.
That the vibration of this
system, the free vibration,
can be made up of
the sum of two parts
at any vibration of
this system at all.
So at any arbitrary set
of initial conditions
I give it-- I let it go.
The key concept is
the response will
be made up of two
pieces-- vibration
in each of the two modes.
And if you can solve
the vibration that's
in first mode-- first mode
is the one where they're
going kind of
together, second mode
they're opposite one another.
That the total
solution can be made up
of a contribution for mode
one and a contribution
from mode two.
So this is this concept
called mode superposition.
It's really quite powerful.
So you can figure out the
response of the first mode
in the system, figure out the
response of the second mode's
contribution, add them together,
and that's the total solution.
And this concept works--
there's all sorts of caveats
that one gets into-- but
basically this is true
for all lightly damped systems.
You get into heavy damping
and strange damping,
you have to make
some adjustments.
But for lightly
damped systems you'll
find that this concept
of mode superposition
works out just fine.
So an illustration of this, a
really simple illustration--
in some ways easier
than this one.
I don't know if I can get
this where you can see it
in the picture or not.
Maybe not really.
This is just two
little lead weights.
This is a double pendulum.
It has two natural frequencies.
One is that one.
You can see the two weights
going the same direction.
The bottom weight at a
little bit more larger angle
than the top weight.
And it's at a
particular frequency.
And that's the mode shape that
goes through this frequency.
So another key concept is
that for free vibration
the total solution is made
up of the free vibration
of each mode.
And each mode has a
particular frequency
and a particular shape to it.
So that's the first mode
frequency and the first mode
shape.
The second mode-- I have a
little harder time getting it
started-- it looks like that.
Masses move in
opposite directions.
It's kind of rotating around
where you can't see it.
I have to do it in the plane.
It's hard to do here.
It doesn't want to behave
like it's confined to a plane.
They're going
opposite directions.
And the frequency is higher.
But this motion,
that mode shape,
is a fixed feature of
this mode of vibration
along with this
natural frequency.
So this idea of
mode superposition--
and a second concept here
is that for free vibration
of each mode it oscillates at
a unique frequency for this two
degree of freedom system.
You have two natural
frequencies--
omega 1 and omega 2.
And at each omega n there is
a corresponding mode shape.
So any vibration of a linear
system, free vibration of it,
any vibration at all is composed
of a superposition of the two
modes.
Part of this motion
is in the first mode
at its natural frequency
and in its shape.
And part of the motion
has a second contribution,
which is at the natural
frequency of the second mode
and in its shape.
So I'm going to give
you a quick demo
and ask you-- let's if
you can use what I just
said to analyze a motion.
So this is just a
block on some strings.
And I'm going to
show you a motion.
And I want you to
tell me whether or not
it could possibly be a natural
frequency motion in one mode,
or the other answer is it's
a sum of multiple modes.
But I'm going to
show you a motion,
and I want you to
tell me and argue
on the basis of what I've
just told you whether or not
you are seeing a single
mode of vibration.
And maybe I'll
use the clamp here
so I don't have to
stand there and hold it.
I'm going to just place this.
So the way you do
free vibration is
you give it an
initial displacement,
some initial
conditions, and let go.
So I'm going to pull this
over and back and let go.
And just watch closely
what you see it do.
All right, now it's doing
more of what I want.
It's like it's going
in a circle right now.
And now it looks like it's
just going back and forth
on a diagonal.
And then it's going to start
circling the other way.
It's going in a circle.
And now it goes to on the
diagonal-- left and right.
And then it starts back
into a circle again.
Are you observing a
natural mode of vibration?
It looks like it's
single frequency, right?
This looks like it's all
happening at one frequency.
But is it a natural mode,
a unique natural mode?
Who wants to make a case
for whether it is or isn't?
How many believe
that you're seeing
a natural mode of vibration?
None.
How many think you're not seeing
a natural mode of vibration?
Let's see if you're awake.
OK.
So you don't believe
that it's natural mode.
Make the case.
Why?
How do you use sort of this
definition of a natural mode
to tell me why this can't be?
AUDIENCE: It looks
like a superposition
of at least two different
kinds of vibration.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
The evidence that you see
is because what does it do?
AUDIENCE: It circled sometimes.
And sometimes it goes straight
back and forth on a diagonal.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
So it circled around
part of the time
and then goes straight back
and forth part of the time.
Is it a constant mode
shape of vibration?
No.
And that's all you
need to observe.
If the thing doesn't keep
a constant single shape
at a single frequency,
it's not a natural mode.
So let's do a different case.
I'll deflect it just this way.
And ignore that
little bit of torsion.
So it's just going
back and forth in line.
Other than slowly damping out,
that has just one motion to it,
and it's at one
natural frequency.
So do you think that's a mode?
That probably is two.
And so is this one.
And ignore that high frequency.
Now it's just back and forth.
It's just a pendulum.
And it just stays in just
pendular motion, no circling
around or any of that.
So that's also
natural, and it occurs
at a particular frequency.
So these are two individual
pendular emotions--
one this way and one that way.
And what I was doing
at the beginning
is I pulled it to
the side, which
would start one of those modes.
And I pulled it
back, which will put
some energy into the
other mode, and let it go.
And now what you have is the sum
of these two different motions
adding up.
It goes in circles and
then in straight lines.
And the fact that they-- this
is a phenomenon called beading.
And it is because
these two pendulums,
even though they have
strings of the same length,
they actually have slightly
different natural frequencies.
They're each single
degree of freedom systems.
They're two independent single
degree of freedom systems,
each with their own
natural frequency.
But if you mix them then they're
going to exhibit this motion.
So that's something really
important to remember.
A quiz question that I like
to ask is-- it's easy to grade
and it's no math required--
is to literally-- I've often
done this in exams--
walk in with something
like that block of wood and
say, is this a natural mode?
Time to do one--
let me see here.
So now let's pick up where
Professor Gossard left off.
Let's go talking about
natural frequencies and mode
shapes of linearized two
degree of freedom systems.
But I want to generalize a
little bit on what he did.
So he, in his lecture,
analyzed this system like this.
I'll just kind of put
the highlights here.
And this is now solving for
natural frequencies and mode
shapes.
He came up with a set of
equations of motion for this.
This was, I guess, M1, M2.
And the equations of motion
for this are m1 in matrix form.
Now I'm going to do this
to emphasize something.
In general there
could be damping
in our linearized system.
And we have a stiffness
matrix-- K1 plus K2 minus K2.
And in general there
could be forces,
which are functions of
time on that system.
Now, if we want to find natural
frequencies in mode shapes,
we go looking for what we
call with the undamped natural
frequencies in mode shapes.
So this problem doesn't
even have dampers in it.
But if it did for the
purpose of finding
natural frequencies in mode
shapes, you just set to 0.
And with the forces
you do the same thing.
And now you have undamped,
unforced equations of motion.
And this is then of the
form of mass matrix times
an acceleration vector, X1,
X2, plus a stiffness matrix,
times a displacement
vector equals 0.
So in matrix notation
it looks like that.
This is the way you would do any
rigid body vibration problem.
This is two degrees of freedom.
But this is the
general expression
for an n degree
of freedom system.
If we had three masses here,
then these would be 3 by 3
matrices instead of 2 by 2's.
So that's the basic formulation.
And you went through
last time with 2 by 2.
You can actually go through and
find the fourth order equation
in omega and solve for two
roots of omega squared.
And you've got the two natural
frequencies, plug them back in.
You've got the two mode shapes
that go along with them.
So you did it that
way by hand so you
can see how you can work
out the natural frequencies.
How can you do-- I'm going to
show an approach that you'd
more likely use on a computer.
And if you get the larger order
n degree of freedom systems,
you're going to want to do
this-- instead of by hand--
have a computer do
the work for you.
So this is the generic form.
And let's just
assume for a minute
it's an n degree
of freedom system.
So these are n by n matrices.
How would we find the
natural frequencies and mode
shapes of this general system?
So you assume
solutions of the form
of what I've been
describing-- a natural mode.
Any natural mode of the
system has a particular shape
to it and a
particular frequency.
And that's the key.
That's the key assumption here.
You assume solutions of the
form that this vector x--
instead of writing it
in brackets like this,
I'm going to make this.
So X here is just with
a line underneath it.
So x is of the form
X1 of t down to Xn
if you have n
degrees of freedom.
You're looking for a
solution for that thing.
And it's going to have
an amplitude to it--
A1 down to An.
And this is any one mode.
So any one mode will look
like a set of amplitudes
that govern its mode shape.
And it will oscillate.
We can write the
oscillation as cosine omega.
And I'll put an i here, it's
the i-th natural frequency
minus some phase angle.
So in general, each
mode-- assume solutions--
I'll say here for each mode.
So each mode, any mode,
mode I will look like this.
It will have a shape
to it governed by this.
And these are
basically on constants.
Once determined, this
is just a constant.
And here's your time dependence.
And it's going to-- I
left out my t-- oscillate
at some natural frequency.
So we know this is what the
solution has to look like.
And we can take this and
plug it in to this equation.
This vector of responses
is some vector of amplitude
times the cosine
omega t minus phi.
And just plug that into this
set of matrix equations.
Note that x double dot is just
a-- you get minus omega squared
a cosine omega t.
And we now substitute
these into here.
You get minus omega
squared for the first term.
Minus omega squared
times the mass
matrix a cosine
omega t minus phi,
plus this stiffness matrix
a-- better consistent notation
here, excuse me-- a
cosine omega t minus phi.
And all that's equal to zero.
So these go away.
You can cancel them out.
And we can factor
out this a quantity.
And we have minus omega squared
m, plus k times a equals 0.
So you can do this
with any linearized n
degree of freedom
system that you know
has a vibration solution to it.
These are the
unknown mode shapes.
And so in order to
satisfy this equation,
either this a has to be 0,
which is a trivial solution.
There's no motion,
no mode shape--
or which this is
trivial, not too useful.
Either a has to be 0, or the
determinant of this quantity
has to be 0.
But the way you do
that on a computer--
so that would be
beginning the way
you would analyze this by hand.
You find the determinant
of that matrix.
And if it is a two
degree of freedom system,
you'll get an equation n
omega to the fourth, which has
two roots for omega squared.
If it's a three degree
of freedom system,
you'll get an equation of omega
to the sixth when you write out
that determinant.
And it has three roots
for omega squared.
An n degree of
freedom system has
an equation that's of order
2n omega to the 2nth power.
And it'll have n
solutions or roots
for the natural frequency
for omega squared.
But that would be
if you're trying
to grind this out by hand.
The way you do this on
a computer-- maybe I
can get a little
bit more on here.
Come back here.
So I'll go back to the earlier
form I had here plus ka
equals 0.
And I'm going to
multiply by m inverse.
So if I invert the
mass matrix, if I
multiply a matrix by its
inverse, what do you get?
So if I multiply
m times m inverse?
AUDIENCE: A unit matrix.
J. KIM VANDIVER: You get
a unit matrix, right?
It has ones on the diagonal.
So I'm going to multiply
through here by this.
And so this gives me
a minus omega squared.
And m times m inverse
gives me the unit matrix--
ones on the diagonal.
Times a plus M inverse
times ka equals 0.
And this product is just a
matrix product-- m inverse
times k.
And I'm going to
call it the a matrix.
And I'm going to move
this to the other side.
So I have a linear
algebraic expression
of the form a times the
vector equals omega squared
times the unit matrix times a.
And I could go ahead
and multiply this out.
For example, this times
that and I'll get a vector.
So this just looks
like omega squared
a if you multiply it out.
The vector times the matrix
is a vector on the left side.
A vector times a matrix
gives me back a vector.
It's just the unit matrix.
So it gives me back the
vector times omega squared.
This is in what is known
as standard eigenvalue
formulation.
It's a standard
eigenvalue problem now.
It's a problem of the form
a times a vector equals
something lambda times a.
A parameter which
we know happens
to be the frequency squared.
But this is standard
eigenvalue formulation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just
asking if you wrote down
omega squared a because it's
equal to the length up there.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Ah, good.
Omega squared a.
So a times the unit vector
you get a back as a vector.
And I got the omega
squared in front of it.
And oftentimes in a manual
for Matlab or something
they'll describe this
as some parameter.
It's a constant times a.
And this is standard what they
call eigenvalue formulation.
And in Matlab if you say, for
example, E equals EIG of A.
This returns a vector, which is
the natural frequency squared.
It will return these lambdas.
And the first one is
omega 1 squared down
to omega n squared.
And if you go with
this function,
if you go a little further,
if you say V comma D is EIG A,
then this gives you
two matrices back.
It gives you V. And
V is a matrix, which
its columns are the mode shape.
So A1 to An, this is mode 1
over to A1 to An for mode n.
It gives you two matrices.
One that's that.
And another one a D matrix,
which has the lambdas-- lambda
1 lambda n on the diagonals.
And it's a diagonal matrix.
So it gives you
two matrices back.
One that has the
eigenvectors, the mode shapes.
And another matrix whose
diagonal elements are
the natural frequency squared.
And that's all there is to it
if you do this numerically.
And there's lots of
different programs.
There's multiple ways
of doing this in Matlab.
When you do it this way it
doesn't come out sometimes
nicely ordered and
what I call normalized.
But it does produce
the eigenvalues.
They're called eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
The eigenvalues are the
lambdas, the natural frequencies
squared.
And the eigenvectors are
these mode shapes that
go with each natural frequency.
Once you know the natural
frequencies and mode shapes,
now we want to get back to
talking about solutions.
This idea of mode superposition.
And if you give it a set
of initial conditions, what
is the response?
How do you add these
two modes together?
So let's go back now.
We'll return to two
degree of freedom systems
like this one to do an example.
And we assume that the solution
was sum A1, A2, cosine omega
t minus a phase angle.
That each mode would have
this character to it.
And I'm going to
normalize my mode shapes.
So for each mode shape
of the system-- so
this could be for mode one.
This is the mode
shape for mode one.
This is natural frequency
one and phase angle one.
Each mode shape-- I
could write this then
as-- I could factor out the A1.
Just pull out A1, divide
each member by A1.
So this can be written as
A1 times 1 and A2 over A1.
So I've just factored out.
So for mode one it's
normalized mode shape--
by normalize you just pick some
way that you repeatedly use,
consistent in its use.
I often say let's make the
top element of the vector 1.
And to make the top
one 1 you factor out
whatever its value is that
you get back from the computer
or from your calculation.
You factor that out
of every member.
Now you have a normalized mode
shape whose top element is 1.
There's lots of other
normalization schemes.
That's just one way to do it.
And that's one of
the mode shapes.
The total solution
is X1, X2-- and this
is where the mode
superposition part comes in--
is some undetermined constant
A1 times the mode shape
A2 over A1 for mode 1 cosine
omega 1 t minus phi 1.
And I'm going to
run out of room.
And now the responses to
initial conditions-- this
has got another term.
I'm just going to
rewrite it here.
So we're looking at--
our total motion response
now by mode superposition will
be A1, 1 A2 over A1, mode 1.
So the free vibration
response of any two degree
of freedom system,
linearized equation, any two
degree of freedom linear
system can be made up
of the sum of two terms.
The motion at its first natural
frequency in its first mode
shape.
And another term is the motion
at a second natural frequency
and its second mode shape.
But now you have two
undetermined constants
out here-- A1 and A2.
Where do they come from?
You have to use your initial
conditions to get those.
I'll write down-- let's see.
I have just maybe enough
time to write this down.
These are functions of time.
So A1 and A2 come from the
ICs, the initial conditions.
So at t equals 0, for example,
plug in t equals 0 into here.
You get cosine phi.
And over here another phi 1
and another way over here.
Cosine of minus phi
1 is cosine phi 1.
So if you put in t equals
0, you find out the X1
at 0, which I'll write
X1 0, and X2 of 0
is equal to-- I'll
actually write them out.
This is going to be A1 times
1 cosine phi 1, plus A2 times
1 cosine phi 2.
And the second equation
that this gives you is A1--
and now to keep from writing
these many, many times,
I'm going to let this
first A2 over A1 for mode 1
be R1, and the second one
A2 over A1 for mode 2.
I'll just call it R2.
And then I can write this out.
So the second equation,
this is R1 cosine phi 1,
plus A2 R2 cosine phi 2.
And now I have
initial conditions
that are normally given.
This is an initial
displacement on 1
and a initial displacement on 2.
The phis I don't know.
And the A's I don't know.
I have four unknowns
and two equations.
How do I get two more equations?
I take the derivative of this
expression to get velocity.
And I get an A omega
here and an A omega here.
And I plug in t equals 0.
And I get two more equations.
So X1 dot and X2 dot
equal at t equals 0.
This gives me two
more equations.
And if I have a place to
write them-- for example,
X1 dot-- or X1 0 dot, the
initial condition on velocity.
X2 dot-- this is two equations.
I've only got time to
write down one of them.
And you could do the
other for exercise.
You find this is A1 omega
1 sine phi 1, plus A2 omega
2 sine phi 2.
And the second equation is you
get A1 R1 omega 1 sine phi 1,
plus A2 R2 omega 2 sine phi 2.
So now you have one, two.
And this is the initial
conditions on velocity.
These are initial
values of velocity.
Now you have one, two, three,
four equations and one,
two, three, four unknowns--
the A1, A2, phi 1, phi 2.
And I guess I will give you the
answer, so you have it once.
So a little tedious but this
is sort of in the spirit of we
do two degree of
freedom systems so
that we can see how it works.
And then for larger
degrees of freedom systems
you would do this
with a computer.
But the solution for A1
is 1 over R2 minus R1.
It's all in terms now
of things you know.
These R2's and R1's are
part of the mode shape,
and the rest is
initial conditions.
R2 x1 0, minus X2 0
squared, plus R2 V1 0,
minus V2 0 quantity
squared, over omega 1
squared, the whole
thing square root.
But now this is
all stuff you know.
The given initial
conditions on velocity,
given initial conditions
on displacement.
You know the natural frequency.
You know the pieces
of the mode shapes.
Just plug it in, you're
going to get a number.
The magnitude of A1 for the
given initial conditions.
A2-- a very similar expression--
minus R1 X1 0 plus x2 0
squared And you'd
solve for A2 and phi
1-- it's a little simpler--
minus tangent inverse,
phi 2 0 minus R2 V1 0, all over
omega 1 R2 x1 0, minus x2 0.
That's one of the phase angles.
And the other phase angle,
a very similar expression.
Minus tangent inverse, minus
R1 V1 0, plus V2 0 omega
2 R1 x1 0, minus x2 0.
So just expressions in terms of
the initial conditions and you
can get all four quantities.
You can also do this
on the computer.
But in the few short
lectures that we have
we're not going
to get into that.
But this just shows
you where it goes.
You could do this now.
There are straightforward
ways of doing it
with matrix algebra
on the computer.
Next time I'll do maybe just a
quick example-- I didn't quite
get to it today-- of a response
to initial conditions problem.
Plug it in there.
See what happens.
But we're out of time.
See you on Thursday.